[Music]
one of my favorite days of the year at
MIT is commencement standing in Killian
Court looking out over a sea of faces
who have just had one of the most
amazing and transformational educational
experiences that they could have you
look out in the audience and you see
people from all over the world literally
and more important than that you see so
many different cultures so many
different mindsets and I think the great
thing is that you see it there together
let me tell you about an interesting
experience I have I actually lead the
undergraduates into Killian Court as we
do that we always stop and allow the
class that is from 50 years ago to go
ahead of us so that that sets up a very
interesting contrast because I can
literally look in front of me and see
the class as reflected from 50 years ago
and I can look behind me and actually
see the class as it is you know today in
some notable ways MIT was much less
diverse there were only a handful of
women Nonis it was the class
predominantly male but it was of a
single ethnic group but in a lot of ways
in terms of spirit and interests and
culture I would say that the class of
1950 and the class of 2010 are not much
different I talked to the people from 50
years ago and they remember those days
and they were young and energetic and
full of dreams changed the world and I
talked to the class today and the young
and energetic and full of Dreams to
change the world
[Music]
in the 19th century students usually
came to MIT to study the useful arts the
useful arts would have been mechanical
engineering civil engineering
architecture and then they were followed
by Electrical Engineering
besides being male and native-born and
white the typical student they tended to
be older they lived in rooming houses
they were more grown-up in many ways
sons of working people I would say most
of them came from middle class
backgrounds the number of women at MIT
was very small compared to the number of
men and the number of blacks at MIT was
even smaller yet and then you do have a
small number of students from primarily
Asia who come to MIT to develop skills
that will help their country to develop
technological independence I guess you
could call it technological nationalism
the thing that is amazing to me about
this place is that William Barton Rogers
vision of men's at Nana's mind and hand
has held up so well over the years and
they obviously expanded and changed but
it's still basically there
how many institutions can make that sort
of claim
[Music]
MIT is maybe unique in the extent to
which its evolution was thoughtful and
fought ahead of time when you think of a
university you think of a much broader
agenda it's not just engineers it's
schools of science humanities Social
Sciences when Karl Compton arrived at
MIT in 1930 the shift began Compton was
brought in to really boost the role the
sciences here and to make them co-equal
partners with engineering he began to
bring the MIT first class scientists by
the time Killian became president you
could begin to speak of the Institute as
being a science-based University and by
1970 let's say all the sciences at MIT
or world class and the humanities were
on the way up
no technical knowledge cannot weigh
knowledge of the humanities in the
gaining of which philosophy and history
walk hand in hand where Winston
Churchill actually came and David talk
where basically he said this institution
should have a School of Humanities the
School of Humanities Arts and Social
Sciences was started because the war had
proved that the implications of science
and engineering went far beyond the
laboratory or even industry we all are
proficient in using the tools we all go
after challenging problems and in doing
so we can forget the human human
interaction we can forget that it's not
just about water purification but it's
about the individuals who are drinking
the purified water once you develop the
water purification system it's
interesting that as the students that we
admit struggle to choose which college
they want to attend they're not looking
really at other institutes of technology
so much they're looking at the other
world-class universities you don't have
to sacrifice your interests in the
humanities in the arts when you come to
MIT then in fact you can have it all
you know having programs like the
humanities and Social Sciences enriches
the educational experience I think it
puts them in a position to go out into
the world and be literate about politics
about society about cultural affairs
that's very important and I think it's
really a key dimension to undergraduate
education at MIT
[Music]
the gender balance in the freshman class
1950 compared with 2011 there's enormous
ly different MIT had women from it's
almost its earliest days but never had
very many in part because it wasn't
something that was pushed on girls but
in part because there was no housing for
women on the campus in the 1960s a girls
dorm had been built thanks to the
generosity of one of the early coeds
Kathryn Dexter McCormick she said I want
to build a dormitory for women and the
first tower of McCormick Hall was built
when she saw how well it was going she
said I'll build a second tower also and
through that interval the numbers
increased dramatically once it was there
it was a constant reminder that it
should be filled and it should expand
and that women belonged here the
administration started to take very
seriously finding out how to introduce
more diversity when I first entered MIT
in 1982 MIT was about 20% female and by
the time I had left in 1986 we were
getting close to about a third
so that start of getting near gender
parity continues so walking down the
infinite corridor it's just a different
world
changeless for minority students began
also in the 60s prior to 1968 the number
of african-american kids in a class
could be counted on two hands usually on
one in 1968 there were two
assassinations first Martin Luther King
and next Bob Kennedy and they shook the
nation they particularly shook the
minority community broadly put the Black
Student Union presented a list of
demands to the administration except we
actually called them proposals ten and
that's when the administration formed
the task force on educational
opportunity and asked Paul gray deleted
now I must say the point of view that I
had at the time was that if the
Institute wasn't going to do it on its
own then it left no choice but for
students to be engaged and we quickly
learned that if we were going to
increase the number of african-americans
here the key was to begin recruiting MIT
had not recruited up to that point
anyone and so it involved a real
commitment on the part of the
administration and on the part of
students because students were actually
going out and recruiting and so there
wouldn't be a real presence if it
weren't for what went on during that
period
the tough part of diversity is that when
you bring a group of folks together that
are different then you're going to come
up with different answers and that's
challenging because it forces you to
rethink what you think is right
diversity does not mean sacrificing
excellence we need to bring all of the
talent to bear if we are to remain the
leader in the areas of research and
education and in some respects the
students now see beyond their own
ethnicity their own culture and they're
more willing to connect students today
there's no majority race and ethnicity
on campus it's a real very diverse set
of students and much more so certainly
than the class of nineteen fifty but
even in the class of 1960 class of 1970
1980 and class of 1990 MIT definitely
has a long way to go but what's exciting
is that I do see a number of elements in
place that will really help to give us
do
[Music]
a large student living group resides in
the dormitories and enjoys a type of
community living roommates work together
harmoniously inside this door it's
strictly no men allowed here the coeds
congregate between classes and relax
from the pressure of classwork
in typical feminine fashion the girls
take time out to gossip about clothes
and dates exchange news and congratulate
or sympathize with one another about
their grades part of my job is to go out
and recruit students to MIT at the
graduate level and so everyone's asking
well wasn't MIT student like is there a
typical MIT student what's the
experience like it MIT and part of your
challenge is going to be is there a
common thread that sort of ties what
seems to be very different individuals
together and if there's a way to pull
out that common thread while not
negating the individuality then I think
that will enhance the work that you do
[Music]
I'd say the one thing we do have in
common is that none of us leave here
with our sanity yeah they're not like
normal and like what their interests are
cuz I fit very unique and that they want
to do but they're not like people at all
like just really friendly when I was
thinking about who to interview the
first person that came to mind was
someone named Kevin so I went to call
him on my phone and it turns out I got
Devon and Kevin confused on my phone so
that's why we are interviewing Devon
today so Devon is there a typical MIT
student there's I would say there is not
a typical MIT student then I have some
typical traits the typical MIT student
is exceptionally passionate in other
words you might use this obsessiveness
good I see more of the obsession for the
thing itself as in you know you really
really like your life which is what you
do it there are a wide variety of
different kinds of students here it's
like any climate there Mike requirements
if not here you'll usually find me at
the computer lab so my favorite computer
is one where you can kind of monitor the
whole area but there's another
architecture student Rudy who also liked
that place oh and he wakes up earlier
than I did
MIT students are hardworking they might
have some sleep deprivation but we're
pretty different I think I can express
it best by sharing a comment that a
former colleague has made then he says
the odds are good and the good sir
this is basically the symbol of our
might here the fire hose you have all
that knowledge thrown at you but there's
so much of it that you will get very
little of it over the years I have
really come to just love MIT students
they're very curious and then they get
involved with the other students in the
classroom it's pretty cool to see like
all these students getting along you
don't just have like a group of people
who are like sticking together or not
interacting with others program together
I'll actually as I might do - it's
called Mike's so science
it's XM minority introduction to
engineering inside it's a great program
[Music]
so do I like MIT yes I actually do I
mean definitely the sleepless nights it
can be a pain but overall the experience
has been pretty amazing about a third of
our students when they come here
you know don't say they want to do
mechanical engineering or they want to
do electrical engineering what they say
is they want to solve the energy problem
I think the MIT student really views
themselves as part of a bigger picture
the amount of public service and
community service that our
undergraduates participate in is
absolutely exploded in the last few
years our students are doing all kinds
of service projects all over the world
I've sometimes said MIT students outdo
the stereotype of MIT students this
willingness to work hard is really true
and I think that's always been the case
here so if a student from MIT of 1900 a
student from MIT of 1950 a student of
MIT of todaywe're sit down I think they
find that they have a lot in common one
part of their discussion would be around
what the on-campus individual looks like
in the dialogue they would see some
significant differences but I think if
you asked them to close their eyes and
sort of talk about what's on the inside
I think it would be exactly the same
MIT is still in my tea there's an ethos
of the place I'm going to anthropologist
there's a culture it's it's a very very
visible culture
the diversity of MIT is evident just by
looking out at the sea of faces in
Killian Court but a lot of the diversity
you can't see a diversity of ideas the
diversity of interests of the diversity
of thought there is just always this
vibrancy this bigger this openness to
creativity that I just haven't found
anyplace else in all those generations
of students the Institute has turned out
people who do important things and that
hasn't changed
[Music]
whoa hello Michael hi hi congratulations
will mean accepted are you excited yeah
that is definitely not true actually
teachers intentionally make the problems
that's harder so that you have to work
with other students it's more like a
collaborative school like what are some
things that you can explore people first
of all definitely people congratulations
again have a great day thank you you too
okay but
[Music]